[Music]
there's three things that are most
important to chefs first is flavor
second has flavor and third is flavor
flavor rules built on the Fertile former
lake bottom soil of northern Ohio the
chef's garden is a 300 acre family farm
that grows specialty produce for some of
the world's best restaurants the chef's
garden is a small family farm that has
the good fortune of working directly
with some of the greatest chefs in the
world in many cases were working with
plant growers that are breeding to be
able to create new plants not genetic
modification but genetic selection the
farm grows produce of all shapes and
sizes
like miniature carrots these white
strawberries in almost a hundred
varieties of microgreens but the Jones
family wasn't always the chef's garden
my parents have had some very successful
years in 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm and ultimately the
farm collapsed we were dealt a new deck
of cards and found opportunity within a
disaster we met a European influence
chef iris Balin to grow me varieties for
flavor grow me varieties without
chemical I want a zucchini bloom thought
this lady was absolutely crazy little do
we know she knew a heck of a lot more
about it than we did and that really
opened our eyes to another whole world
out there we hooked up with some really
great chefs early on folks like Danielle
Beaulieu and jean-georges Vongerichten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Rashard and
then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and in ritz-carlton chefs and for
seasoned chefs and they've allowed us in
existence in agriculture we're indebted
to those chefs that have given us the
privilege and the path to be able to
follow our dream of farming so it's that
symbiotic relationship of chef and
farmer working together for the greater
good and here we are 35 years later
still working to get better to the best
of our ability right now in this place I
think we're doing the right thing and I
think that trumps every other reason for
whatever you doing this was
[Music]
seaweed is a common ingredient in
Japanese cuisine but there's a unique
type growing in the Pacific Ocean
ma Papa - Thomas okay now Jessica mother
tonight - she's joining sternum on this
[Music]
70 miles of the coast of mainland Japan
is the small island of Okinawa home to
one of the most unusual farming methods
in the world what about you got him I
got you about you ho hold on there kiddo
mr. Oshiro comes from a seafaring family
and today he is one of the farmers
growing mozuku a special seaweed only
grown in these waters moto moto
fishermen Nagarajan my gray no tsukumo
yogi it's got [ __ ] a monster claw well
as you hasn't it each fall a web of nets
are laced with mozuku seedlings on land
then mr. Oshiro and his son lay the nuts
in rows in the shallow water this
ingenious system allows the mozuku to
grow sustainably by not creating
additional waste and when the time is
ripe
it is harvested with two boats and their
giant vacuum
[Music]
Sambia kumatora Shiho no idea God but I
started on a muscular Hyderabad a they
take it on Kara don't miss em before I
go a more pure honesty it's
multitudinous the day's harvest is then
taken to his factory where it's cleaned
weighed and processed then it's off to
the markets to sell his underwater
treasure SAMCRO activist mozuku is in
high demand
it's packed with nutrients so many
people eat it for a health boost but
that wasn't always the case
mozuku ah Mukesh you a poverty to
sunless skin Acosta was Union Local
Union gray micarta you [ __ ] no blue in
color high-pitched a pie so they they
sent a video leptin wah Nagano site in
Colorado monster Sakai is unique musical
hero you can all say ok now optimist in
recent years mr. Oshiro has seen a
change in the ocean so the future of his
Mizuki is uncertain cos a cos I see Amin
Amin energetic
so Coco Sega jubilation Alto most Gazeta
you Oakland
Jakub mastery carat solitaire no they're
against economic system order to a
cancerous
ecology three artists mo amino can Koga
yoga Rito Kunwar your emotional
so no tank unit is you know maybe to
attack America toga tableau me or Mamoru
Cotto I've got a mother we can i buy
Megan okay to need cash tonight oh but a
show -
despite the challenges mr. Oshiro stead
ocation proves this work is more than
just a day job for him it's about
maintaining a family tradition and
passing on his father's respect for the
sea so notice notice Ankara I don't
agree to a man and a such they
congregate a culture today so know each
other
you don't like it oh what a shame Adam
just zero matter
Mosconi it's very radical
hello - no business only see the
criticisms now what I selected I worried
that I see you know see Danny Santos
aligned in Connecticut
[Music]
[Music]
cheep-cheep-cheep hi guys
hi bubbles hi Walter hey dolly hey mama
hi baby hi Albie Jenny's farm didn't
start out with animals that were missing
limbs it just happened to come to her
farm and she felt well prosthetic
technologies helped me it could
certainly help them I can't imagine not
having an artificial leg because I lost
my leg at ten and I'm quite used to it
it's thanks to medical science that I'm
able to live this normal life and for
these animals
I want no different for them hi Felix
what goes on at Woodstock Farm Sanctuary
on a daily basis we're home to right now
around 300 rescued farm animals they've
all come from bad places and they get
the veterinary care the health care that
they need on a daily basis he's feisty
can you come help me with Felix they're
all actually in the front pasture little
Felix came to us as a baby lamb and he
had come from a big sheep farm and
overnight some sort of predator had
gotten in and they found little Felix
with his leg chewed off and so I spoke
to my prophetess the gentleman who makes
my legs Eric
many clinicians would have went out to
the farm I don't have any experience
with fitting prosthetics on animals very
few people in the country do so I
figured if I could take what knowledge
that I do have and apply it to the
animal I could probably get them to
utilize a prosthesis and it wasn't until
we got hooked up with SUNY New Paltz and
their 3d printing lab that we were able
to make something pretty cool and cut
edge for him seeing him walk on the leg
was absolutely amazing from my limited
interactions with him he isn't
necessarily the most outgoing sheep in
the world it was actually a very
sheepish but what he ended up doing was
he'd started running away from us which
was amazing
we were just jumping for joy that he
could actually get up and run keep up
with his flock he looked like he was a
very happy sheep if we could do this
more on other animals we wouldn't have
to you know put them down most of the
world doesn't fully understand it they
think of them as just farmed animals but
we hope that that changes and that's
part of the magic of what we do here
they get pastures to roam in access to
the Sun and to the grass they live life
the way they were intended to live
there's no greater joy
[Music]
goody we can grow giant models for foot
in a month 45 inches
these models would taste exactly the
same as a normal model nice and tender
unless some of them look a bit tough but
once you cut into them they cut like
butter my name is Philip Powell's I live
in San Ari Wales and I grow giant
vegetables I've been growing giant
vegetables now for the last 30 years I
come from a very large family
my mother had 17 children 13 of us
survived and I think you know that was
something you know big vegetables feed
big families you know I'm up here every
morning every night
every single day of the week there's a
lot of love and cake was into it
sometimes I do better talking to them as
well to encourage them to grow which is
a bit of a bit of fun you know I think
he's just about finished grow in there
now I got to be very careful the wife is
not about when I start talking to my
vegetables but this all good fun I broke
the world record for the heaviest
cucumber about 25 years ago it radiates
in a half pound and it was just
incredible the way true you know when I
started if we had a morrow 20 30 pound
in weight you are the bay tomorrow now
we're up over hundred pound in weight
normal cabbage would be two pound in
weights but we are growing I'm 100 and
20 pound you know you can feed 120
hundreds 240 people off one cabbage this
is why I supply the local pub and they
use a mapper Sunday lunch I've developed
my own strain more or less now I select
my own seed every year the biggest and
the best seed and it just seems to be
improving which is incredible I grow
organically I just think if I can do it
anybody
do it and it's a big thrill every day
the wife say what am i doing up
allotment every day and when she comes
up she realized
[Music]
Rosabelle is originally pursued Ice
Hotel Security's if anything while Eric
tries to tell the mayor fasten a
position opens the other pilot Ida
militate a female patient Luther
conseguir the National military lapel or
annually just Shockley's wear a suit or
less than adjusts affair yep although a
q-tip or not consummate can burn sermon
on a barbaric austerity or no
so Tory will give a premium for Lisa
sponsor who race at all
[Music]
but normally technique industrial metal
or no less well Eric style just an idea
when you answer easily
Giovanna TK between cream a pyramid
metadata select commercial segment which
convey deformities with a value
parameter traditional was it - Jacques
illicit activity de su material sabotage
or postulated Patil Cheniere does
intravenous oculist operation organism a
parmesan - definitionally dyani is if I
ask you you buy cookies any Content ID
recommendation P or at least here in the
Burpee no couch on pony horse or family
sale a large mafia - Tessa were give us
Benton killer with the CC convey
evaluate so champion he saw that they
have to achieve we worry to diesel was
here was here was here yeah I am
actually
so now that cotton would have raised a
bit hard but try item Yaffe
[Music]